je remplis et notre invité politique ce
matin c'est marion maréchal bonjour je
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous vous
êtes le soutien d'eric zemmour et bien
candidat à la présidentielle pour son
mouvement reconquête en détention
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par fabrice veysseyre redon
du groupe ebra bonjour fabrice bonjour
orione on va évidemment parler du
programme et de la campagne d'eric
zemmour mais un mot sur l'actualité
c'est l'ukraine et on a vu ces images
terribles 40ème jour de guerre en
ukraine les forces russes qui se retire
de la région de kiev et des dizaines de
corps qui ont été retrouvés dans la
ville de boudhha le président ukrainien
accuse la russie de commettre un
génocide la russie dément est ce que
comme emmanuel macron vous dites que les
autorités russes devront répondre de ses
crimes ce qui est certain c'est que les
images terribles auxquelles nous avons
assisté ont toutes les apparences d'un
crime de guerre pour le coup donc il est
important que la cour pénale
internationale puisse s'emparer de cette
affaire mener une enquête indépendante
établir des responsabilités et en effet
condamné la russie si ces faits sont
confirmés avery tel qu'il se présente ça
c'est absolument évident ça nous
rappelle d'ailleurs la l'impérative
nécessité de voir ce conflit en
désescalade et de trouver une porte de
sortie de ce point de vue d'ailleurs les
négociations ou en tout cas les annonces
qui ont été faites en turquie soit assez
encourageantes malgré tout côté russe et
côté ukrainien puisque on semble pouvoir
avancer vers cette solution même
imparfaite qui irait vers la neutralité
de l'ukraine et en parallèle des
garanties de sécurité pour l'ukraine
donc j'ai s'avère qu'aujourd'hui une
solution diplomatique est envisageable
il faut dire avant tout cas les signaux
que nous avons eu hier sont
encourageants et intéressants de ce
point de vue là et donc je crois que le
rôle de la france dans ces états dans
cette affaire c'est d'accompagner au
maximum cette porte de sortie qui est la
seule solution que nous ayons
satisfaisante ce protéger le peuple
ukrainien ce qui a été fait jusqu'à
présent par la france et par emmanuel
macron particuliers ou semble
satisfaisant en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que le président emmanuel macron
eu raison de maintenir le dialogue voilà
c'est malheureusement il se trouve que
ça n'est pas la france qui a été le
médiateur semble-t-il le plus le plus
efficace en je crois que ça tient
à beaucoup de choses notamment au fait
que notre voie diplomatique depuis des
années maintenant et relativement noyé
dans une dans une voie diplomatique ou
pseudo diplomatique de l'union
européenne qui est assez à saisissable
est assez disparate le fait également
que du point de vue russe en tout cas
comme du point de vue chinois et
d'autres puissances notre voix est
considérée comme alignée sur celle des
états unis du fait de notre
participation au sein de l'organisation
de sécurité de l'otan et que de ce fait
là nous avons plus de difficultés à être
entendu comme une puissance à la fois
militaire et diplomatique
autonome et indépendante et je me prends
la finance est idiot et bien aujourd'hui
panda 2 fait de fait on voit bien que
malgré les efforts entrepris nous
n'avons pas réussi à être le médiateur
le médiateur espérer voilà je crois que
malgré tout c'est l'honneur de la france
d'essayer de garder un maximum d'antenne
de bronze sans cette interdépendance
pardon dans cette affaire et d'éviter
dans une d'être dans une espèce
d'escaladé à la fois verbale et dans les
actes qui ne ferait qu'aggraver la
situation du peuple craint dernier mot
là dessus est ce que si la guerre en
russie prend fin dans une ukraine prend
fin comme comme on l'espère tous c'est
ce que la russie peut revenir dans le
concert des nations et ce que vladimir
poutine pour redevenir un interlocuteur
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'une fois que de
toute façon les responsabilités auront
été établies nous n'avons pas le luxe de
pouvoir mettre au ban de concert des
nations européen et mondial la russie
que ça nous plaise ou non nous avons des
relations également avec la chine dont
tout le monde sait que c'est un régime
autoritaire pour ne pas dire totalitaire
on sait la manière dont il se comporte
avec les ouigours nous avons des
relations avec l'arabie saoudite à qui
on pourrait faire les mêmes reproches et
on se souvient tous de la guerre au
yémen donc malheureusement le monde est
ainsi fait que nous n'avons pas le luxe
de pouvoir nous priver d'entretenir des
relations qu'elles soient diplomatiques
ou économiques
avec presque taxis les pays du monde les
glacis si vous voulez le problème c'est
que la russie ne va pas soudainement
disparaître du continent européen vous
savez aujourd'hui les dépendances qui
sont les nôtres notamment sur le plan
énergétique alors j'entends volontiers
la nécessité et je la partage
d'expliquer qu'il faut maximum viser
l'autonomie
énergétique notamment sur le plan du
nucléaire mais néanmoins nous n'avons
pas de solution à l'instant t immédiate
à très court terme pour pouvoir pallier
cette cette dépendance sur le plan
pétrolier et gazier
donc de ce point de vue là bon il faut
il faut savoir être faire de la
realpolitik comme on dit être
pragmatique malheureusement ne pas
toujours très agréable de travailler
avec des partenaires en effet
contestable dans leurs actes aujourd'hui
tous les appareils de la campagne du
programme d'examen parce qu'on est à 6
jours maintenant du premier tour la
principale préoccupation des français
c'est le pouvoir d'achat est ce qu'en
négligeant cette thématique eric zemmour
il n'a pas fait une erreur d'analysé qui
pourrait expliquer sa chute dans les
sondages alors je ne crois pas du tout
qu'il les négligés en dépit de ce qui a
été dit le choix qu'il a fait lui
c'était de dire je ne veux pas mettre en
compétition la question du pouvoir
d'achat et la question de l'identité là
il a justifié son entrée en campagne en
disant je veux être celui qui évite le
ronronnement si je peux dire autour des
sujets qu vie des sanitaires à l'époque
en septembre lorsque la campagne a
commencé et puis nous avons eu cette
guerre il a dit malheureusement les
crises de s'annule pas elle se cumulent
et de ce point de vue là nous ne pouvons
pas avoir nous permettre le luxe
d'abandonner la question de la sécurité
la question de l'immigration et les
mettre de côté donc il a fait le choix
de maintenir ce sujet et parce qu'il
l'est il ay là comment dire chercher à
les mettre en avant lui a reproché
sacrifier le pouvoir d'achat mais quand
je vous pouvez vous pencher sur son
programme c'est un programme extrêmement
ambitieux à près de 28 milliards d'euros
de pouvoir d'achat rendu aux français 32
milliards ou également de compétitivité
rendus aux entreprises financées par des
économies à hauteur de 65 milliards donc
vous y retrouver des mesures pour pour
les familles avec le retour
l'universalité par exemple allocations
familiales pour les salariés avec une
augmentation des bas salaires jusqu'à
2000 euros par la baisse de la csg vous
allez vous y retrouvez également une
possibilité de primes reprises
d'ailleurs par emmanuel macron ce qui
est assez ironique complètement des fils
des objets du coup là dessus sur la
preuve en tout cas c'est amusant de
retrouver dans les débats là dans le
programmes des manuels macro un certain
nombre de mesures
défendues par part
eric zemmour on pouvait retrouver aussi
par exemple l'exonération totale des
heures supplémentaires enfin voilà il ya
quand même beaucoup de mesures qui sont
prises très concrètes pour faciliter la
vie des français de ce point de vue la
face à la hausse des prix de
l'alimentaire puisque les français vont
être content confronté à ça une mission
déjà d'ailleurs confrontés est ce que
pour vous il faut instaurer un chèque
alimentaire cri vous êtes élu bon
pourquoi pas sur le principe pour les
plus précaires en effet en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que si l'ensemble des
mesures qui sont défendues aujourd'hui
par par eric zemmour sont mises en place
ce sont parfois jusqu'à plusieurs
centaines d'euros par an et voire même
un treizième mois pour pour les bas
salaires qui serait permis via ces
mesures donc on pourrait espérer et
c'est l'objectif que justement
dorénavant le travail permettent de
satisfaire ses besoins les plus
immédiats ce qui n'est pas toujours
aujourd'hui le cas comme on le constate
pour beaucoup de français sur la
question de l'immigration alors dans le
programme d'eric zemmour en ligne
arrêtée le regroupement familial limiter
le droit d'asile supprimer le droit du
sol mais immigration zéro ce n'est pas
écrit ce n'est plus écrit est ce que
vous y avez renoncé est ce que
finalement vous reconnaissez que
l'immigration zéro c'est pas possible
non au fait si vous voulez l'oubli de
migration 0 c'est un objectif
c'est-à-dire d'expliquer que demain nous
souhaiterions arriver à un solde négatif
sur le fait qu'il y ait plus de sorties
que d'entrée c'est d'ailleurs tout le
sens notamment de ce ministère de la
remise gracieuse qui a été proposé et
qui consiste à dire l'objectif c'est de
dédier un ministère à la sortie d'un
million d'étrangers à l'issue du
quinquennat qui n'ont rien à faire sur
le territoire français et on pense à
travers ces passionnés ce ministère
parce que le terme a parfois choqué
ministère de la remise le cautionne
d'autant plus qu' il ya un sondage qui a
été réalisé et qui prouve qu'une
majorité de français d'ailleurs quels
que soient les familles politiques
exception faite de la france insoumise
partage majoritairement le contenu de ce
ministère à savoir expulser les
délinquants étrangers 80000 condamné
quand même étrange et parents les 25%
détenus dans nos prisons les alors les
chiffres varient si on prenait les
chiffres de patrick stefanini 900 mille
clandestins sur le territoire français
les 4000 fichier s pour radicalisation
c'est cela qui sont visés et
exclusivement visé est donc à ce titre
si vous ajoutez à cela les mesures de
réduction drastique d'immigration l'idée
c'est qu'en effet à l'issue du
quinquennat nous ayons un solde négatif
et donc nous puissions tenir cet
objectif d' immigration zéro de ce point
de vue là il ya quand même des crimes
qu'il faut l'éliminer et le droit
d'asile à quelques individus par an ce
qui sont ces individus et c'est combien
quelques passes et de revenir à l'esprit
initial qui était celui finalement du
droit d'asile c'est à dire pas apporter
d'abord la prit la protection de la
france à ce qu'ils étaient surtout des
réfugiés politiques on voit bien
qu'aujourd'hui malheureusement le droit
d'asile est devenue une filière
d'immigration clandestine des voiliers
puisque plus de 80 % de ce que vous
savez qui arrivent parfois même
clandestinement sur le territoire qui
demandent le droit d'asile ne
l'obtiennent pas mais in fine et
parviennent à rester sur le territoire
français tout simplement parce qu'à
moins de 20% des obligations qu'irriter
le territoire français qui sont
appliquées et donc on voit bien que
finalement il suffit aujourd'hui
d'arriver sur le territoire de faire
cette demande de droit d'asile pour être
certain quasiment de ne jamais être
expulsé du territoire et peut-être même
d'espérer une naturalisation puisque
vous savez que sous emmanuel macron ce à
peu près trente mille naturalisations
par an qui ont été opérées donc voilà
l'idée c'est simplement de faire en
sorte que cette politique s'adresse
prioritairement à de véritables réfugiés
notamment politique et qu'elle puisse
être déposée auprès des ambassades
françaises ou de l'atlantique les
réfugiés craignant aussi et les réfugiés
ukrainiens les al ajilat bénéficie d'un
statut en effet particulier je crois que
de ce point de vue là c'est cohérent
puisque c'est l'état d'esprit que nous
avons en ce qui nous concerne les
réfugiés européens ont vocation à être
d'abord prioritairement accueilli par
les pays européens les réfugiés arabes
par les pays arabes les réfugiés
africains par les pays africains c'est
logique ça permet de conserver une
proximité géographique de faciliter le
retour au pays une fois les choses
apaisé de faciliter aussi l'ajax aignan
qui veulent venir en france il faut les
accueillir dans la mesure de ce que nous
pouvons assumer j'ai envie de vous dire
financièrement et logistiquement parce
que vous savez que chaque fois qu'une
famille ukrainienne arrive il faut
pouvoir bien sûr l'accueillir dans des
conditions décentes c'est à dire la loge
et notamment aux vous connaissez la
tension que nous avons aujourd'hui sur
nos logements sociaux nous avons déjà du
mal à loger notre propre sdf a assuré
même le logement d'aidé ce qu'on appelle
maintenant les mineurs isolés et les
multiples demandes notamment relatives
au droit d'asile donc c'est vrai qu'il
faut pouvoir le faire dans la mesure de
nos moyens et c'est à ce titre
d'ailleurs que il me semble nécessaire
de précisément réduire le dévoiement de
et l'immigration clandestine d'autres
filières pour pouvoir accueillir
davantage ces réfugiés de guerre
ukrainien qui devrait être prioritaire
bien sûr gouvernement sur cette question
des migrations est ce que vous êtes pour
des quotas d'immigration vote et chaque
année au parlement
moi je ne crois pas nécessairement que
ce soit la bonne manière d'aborder les
choses même si j'entends volontiers le
fait qu'il soit utile d'établir les
besoins notamment sur le plan économique
et d'adapter la politique en conséquence
mais ce qu'il faut dire comme
aujourd'hui aux français c'est que
l'immigration de travail est une
numération
extrêmement minoritaire sur l'ensemble
des titres de séjour qui ont été
accordés à des extra européens depuis
début du quinquennat
c'est en moyenne entre 7 et 10% qui
relève de l'immigration de travail donc
ce qui est certain c'est que si on peut
pas sacrifier intégralement ses besoins
en termes d'immigration de travail la
priorité c'est à faire en sorte que ce
soit d'abord de l'emploi français qu'ils
soient favorisés et la deuxième chose de
réduire l'ensemble de l'immigration
adjacentes j'ai envie de dire qu'il ne
répond pas à des besoins économiques et
de faire en sorte que des étrangers des
personnalités étrangères qui se trouvent
durablement au chômage sur le territoire
français n'est plus vocation à rester
parce que malheureusement nous n'avons
plus le luxe de pouvoir supporter cela
un mot sur l'école c'est une des
priorités du programme d'eric zemmour
alors il veut rétablir l'autorité
revenir aux savoirs fondamentaux est ce
que comme emmanuel macron vous êtes pour
laisser la liberté plus de liberté aux
chefs d'établissement
alors ça ne me choque pas sur le
principe encore faut-il voir ce qu'il y
a derrière cette liberté je suis quand
même attaché au fait qu'il y ait un
programme par exemple commun sur
l'ensemble du territoire s'il s'agit
davantage de liberté par exemple dans
les recrutements des professeurs
pourquoi pas dans la sélection dans le
comment dire la mise en place de primes
au mérite
ça pourquoi pas ou sur l'organisation
les professeurs pour vous ben moi ça me
choquerait pas je suis assez attachés à
l'idée du mérite et je trouve que quand
un enseignant a de très bons résultats
il faut pouvoir le récompenser donc si
c'est de cet ordre là oui je suis quand
même attaché une fois plus à un
programme commun donc c'est un peu comme
pour les universités je pense que
l'autonomie universitaire ce principe
est une bonne chose il faut encore en
tilt faut-il en voir les contours et les
filles la croisière le le fait qu'elle
soit vraiment opérationnel et au delà de
la prime au mérite à ce que vous êtes
pour augmenter le salaire des
enseignants abbas qui est sûr c'est que
nous sommes face aujourd'hui à une
précarisation du métier d'enseignant qui
posent de véritables difficultés au
point qu'aujourd'hui il ya une crise des
vocations au point que nous sommes
obligés d'accepter des enseignants qui
parfois n'ont même pas la moyenne au
concours de sélection qu'il faut pas
espérer derrière que notre école soit à
la mesure des attentes donc ce qu'il
faut une grande politique cohérente de
revaloriser leur valorisation de ce
métier à la fois sur le plan salarial
sur le plan du statut sur le plan de la
sélection ça c'est absolument évident et
sur le plan de l'autorité parce que
c'est vrai que beaucoup d'enseignants
dans certains quartiers vivent un enfer
du quotidien et ça ne contribue pas à
leur donner envie de pouvoir enseigner
et vous le savez peut-être revoir aussi
ce système qui est totalement aberrant
qu'on trouve aussi chez les policiers
qui consiste à envoyer les les
enseignants les moins expérimentés dans
les secteurs les plus difficiles à faire
l'inversé il me semble évidemment que il
faille réfléchir à un système qui à
l'envers sans voix les enseignants les
plus expérimentés vers les zones
d'éducation prioritaire un mot sur un
sujet qui préoccupe aussi les français
dans cette campagne c'est la question de
la retraite de la réforme des retraites
vous vous êtes pour la retraite à 64 ans
comment à quelle échéance et est ce que
c'est pour tout le monde à 64 ans ou est
ce qu'il y aura des critères de
pénibilité alors vous avez raison c'est
une réforme qui s'appliquerait de
manière progressive sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat donc l'objectif c'est
d'arriver à 64 ans à la fin du
quinquennat la règle en tant que
progressivement la durée exactement avec
le maintien bien évidemment de tout les
systèmes de départ anticipé qui existent
actuellement pour carrière longue pour
pénibilité pour handicap c'est là
évidemment la moindre des choses
l'objectif des régimes spéciaux aussi de
certains régimes spéciaux en tout cas je
pense que certains se justifie d'autres
non autant je vois une logique à celui
de l'armée je vois une logique moindre à
celui par exemple de la sncf aujourd'hui
au regard de l'évolution des conditions
de travail dans le dans le ferroviaire
en revanche je faut quand même
comprendre l'objectif l'objectif il est
triple si je puis dire le premier un
c'est évidemment de maintenir le
garantir le financement de ce système de
retraite le deuxième c'est de permettre
qu'il y est comment dire une
augmentation des petites retraites
notamment jusqu'à 1300 euros par la
baisse de la csg et c'est surtout de
sauvegarder à tout prix notre régime de
répartition régime de solidarité
nationale pour éviter que ce régime ne
puissent basculer à terme vers un
système de capitalisation qui est un
régime tourner vers le privé qui expose
les retraités aux aléas on va dire du
marché et qui comme on peut le voir en
face à la retraite minimum pendez aurait
un problème non ce que je veux dire
c'est que voilà il faut pouvoir
augmenter en effet ces petites retraites
par la baisse de la csg allez on va
passer à la campagne d'eric zemmour vous
avez regardé emmanuel macron ce week end
en en
campagne à la défense en grande partie
parce que c'était très très long comme à
ce qu'est ce que j'en avais français bah
j'en ai pensé que ça lui ressembler
c'est à dire un espèce de grand show
avec à l'américaine avec comment dire
les dj avec slogans préparer auprès des
jeunes j'ai vu j'ai vu aussi un candidat
qui n'était pas tout à fait cohérent
avec le bilan du président mais
j'imagine qu'on va en parler justement
parce qu'il a quand même eu cette phrase
il a fustigé ceux qui défendent le grand
rabougrissement vos visant très
vraisemblablement qu'est ce que vous en
dites bajon dit que je retrouve là les
vieilles techniques faciles de ceux qui
ne voulant pas répondre sur le fond
politique et sur le bilan en revienne
aux attaques
morales principaux on retrouve un peu
c'est un peu l'équivalent de ce qu'on a
entendu pendant très longtemps avec les
heures les plus sombres de notre
histoire les idées nauséabondes
moi je ne sais pas ce qu'il ya de
rabougri à de vouloir défendre entités
françaises il a notamment fustigé le
politiquement abject est ce que vous
vous souhaite vous êtes sentis visés
avec votre candidat eric zemmour oui ces
magies majine que c'était le but en tout
cas vous l'avez pris pour vous enfin ça
paraît évident et tout le monde l'a
analysée comme ça donc ne tournons pas
autour du pot c'est assez intéressant
d'ailleurs le fait qu'il qu'il vise
aussi directement d'une certaine manière
eric zemmour ça veut dire que à travers
ce duel qu'ils installent ils voient
bien que c'est là que se trouve le
véritable
différentiel sur le plan de la vision et
sur le plan de la politique menée avec
eric zemmour plus qu'avec marine le pen
quand vont ils visaient les deux quand
il disait ça je ne sais pas exactement
mais manifestement dans le tout les
analystes tels qu'on les voit il semble
quand même viser particulièrement
irrigue zemmour moi ce que je constate
si vous voulez c'est ça qui m'a frappé
dans ce discours c'est qu'il ya une
déconnexion entre le président et le
candidat enfin je veux dire je vois un
candidat qui nous explique qui va lutter
contre la désindustrialisation et j'ai
vu un président qui a perdu 5000 emplois
industriels sur le quinquennat je vois
candidats qui nous explique qu'il faut
voilà d'ailleurs réponse une nouvelle
fois eric zemmour soit disant défendre
la france dans son unité parce que la
france est un bloc et la prendre dans
son ensemble et c'est le même président
qui expliquait que les gilets jaunes sur
les ronds-points était une lèpre
populiste que les non vaccinés étaient
des non citoyens et qu'il voulait il ya
quelques mois emmerder les français
c'est un candidat qui explique ya pas
d'argent magique et c'est un président
qui a plus 700 milliards d'euros de
dette supplémentaire et je précise et
c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est un
certain eric woerth avant même de
rejoindre eric zemmour eric zémour
lapsus
emmanuel macron qui dit que hors dette
hors crise par dont l'augmentation de la
dette était de plus de 100 milliards
d'euros voilà donc je pourrais vous le
président n'a pas fait sa ba exactement
je pourrais multiplier les exemples mais
c'est vrai que on a sept cette
ambivalence on a un ce président qui est
capable de faire des embardées
spectaculaire on l'a vu sur le nucléaire
on l'a vu sur les retraites on l'a vu
même sur un sujet un peu plus technique
j'ai envie de dire qu'il touche à
l'autonomie alimentaire qui est
aujourd'hui présenté comme un grand
objectif
alors même que pendant des mois le
président aujourd'hui candidats
défendent et le fameux pacte vert au
niveau européen à travers ces
eurodéputés qui est un pacte qui conduit
à des restrictions
extrêmement drastiques auprès nos
agriculteurs et dont l'étude d'impact
qui a été fait qd concluent à une baisse
de 15% de la production alimentaire si
elle était mise en place un jeu pour
revenir dessus alors oui il faut revenir
dessus mais vous voyez bien que en fait
on se rend compte qu'on est prêt à se
mettre entre les mains d'un homme dont
on ne sait pas à quelle sauce il va nous
manger dans six mois ce qui comme étant
faux bond vous voulez mettre fin au
mandat de macron diviseurs c'est comme
ça que vous l'avez surnommé lors du
meeting de toulon est ce que pour mettre
fin à son mandat aujourd'hui la mieux
placée ce n'est pas marine le pen non je
ne crois pas pour une raison simple
c'est que ce duel a déjà
eu lieu d'une certaine manière et et on
voit bien aujourd'hui que
c'est ce dont je suis convaincu eric
zemmour à des marges de progression et
des capacités de créer la surprise au
second tour dont je pense que marine le
pen ne dispose pas je crois parce qu'il
a ou joël marges ben je crois qu'il a
aujourd'hui une capacité on le voit dans
les français qui sont prêts à voter pour
lui de rassemblement à la fois des
électeurs et rennes est allé on le voit
dans son équipe on le voit dans sa
capacité à briser le cordon sanitaire
avec des personnalités par exemple comme
eric ciotti numéro deux de l air comme
françoise et bellamy chef de la
délégation et là au parlement européen
qui ont d'ores et déjà teasé maintenant
tout à fait mais qui ont d'ores et déjà
dit enquête deuxième tour emmanuel
macron eric zemmour nous voterons pour
eric zemmour est donc on voit bien que
de ce point de vue là il ya une capacité
à créer la surprise que malheureusement
mal de marine le pen selon moi dont elle
ne dispose pas les sondages ne
consolident pas la position d'eric
zemmour s'est démenée ces dernier jours
vous ne regrettez pas d'avoir choisi le
camp d'eric zemmour plutôt de celui de
marine le pen non je regrette pas du
tout parce que j'ai fait là un choix de
conviction et j'ai rejoint un candidat
qui partage et à la fois la stratégie et
la ligne que je défende et moi-même au
front national à l'époque à l'époque où
cette ligne n'était pas partagée et même
parfois parfois combattu donc je ne
préjuge pas
des sondages je pense que il faut savoir
s'en méfier quand ils sont bons comme
quand ils sont mauvais d'ailleurs ce qui
n'est pas toujours le cas il faut bien
l'admettre quand on fait de la politique
et j'ai d'ailleurs je suis retombé sur
une information qui je trouvais
intéressante avant 2002 vous le savez
très certainement il n'y avait pas de
publication de sondages les deux
dernières semaines de l'élection je
trouve que c'était assez sain parce que
ça permettait d'éviter que finalement
les sondages l'influencent l'opinion et
je pense que la mécanique du vote utile
est une mauvaise manière de penser la
démocratie parce qu'on a de très
nombreux exemples en france notamment
est encore très récent de des erreurs
commises par les sondages notamment aux
dernières régionales et même à
l'étranger puisque vous avez vu et
viktor orban a été réélu en gris et je
dis seulement ont donné trois points
d'avance avec l'opposition finalement il
en a 18 donc il faut se méfier des
sondages incidents de campagne ce week
end entre eric zemmour est le frère de
zinedine zidane au cours d'un match de
foot donc eric zemmour a dû quitter les
lieux à la demande de dufrennes zinedine
zidane quelle analyse vous vous portez
quel regard vous portez sur cet incident
bah je trouve ça je trouve ça déplorable
parce qu'en l'occurrence ceux des
militants qui avaient réservé une salle
de foot à marseille couverte pour
pouvoir jouer avec eric dans les règles
de l'art tout avait été réglé rémunérée
pour des raisons de sécurité évidemment
la présence d'éric de façon anonyme mais
pour des raisons de sécurité vous savez
qu'à marseille chaque fois que eric
zemmour se déplace il est harcelé par
une horde d'anti femme manifestement que
le gouvernement n'arrive pas à maîtriser
il se trouve qu'à peine arrivé
en effet des personnes sur place l'ont
menacée ont menacé de faire descendre
les quartiers nord de marseille pour
pour le sortir donc c'est vrai qu'on se
rend compte c'est bien que les français
voient ces images aussi on se rend
compte qu'on est dans un pays où un
candidat à la présidentielle ne peut
plus faire un match de foot sereinement
sans être intimidés menacés de violences
dans certains quartiers de france c'est
pas très rassurant alors robert ménard
que vous connaissez quel maire de
béziers qui est soutien de marine le pen
ce qui n'empêche pas d'être critique
indique eric zemmour un monde où il
exerce un rendu plus audible discours de
marine le pen en montrant qu'on pouvait
être plus dur et plus à droite il accuse
également eric zemmour de mépris de
classe qu'est ce que vous en pensez
j'ai du mal à donner du crédit à la
parole de robert ménard parce que c'est
un homme qui depuis quelques mois a fait
des changements pied assez spectaculaire
on s'en souvient il ya quelques mois il
s'affichait encore comme un ami d'eric
zemmour il était même à le soutenir il
se présentait comme un potentiel agents
réconciliateur entre les deux il a
aujourd'hui manifestement complètement
changé d'idée il a changé d'idée aussi
sur par exemple et on en a beaucoup
parlé les réfugiés syriens en faisant un
parallèle seulement un peu inepte avec
les réfugiés ukrainien puisque à
l'époque évidemment il y avait à travers
cette arrivée des réfugiés syriens une
menace djihadiste majeur du fait que la
syrie était le coeur de l'état islamique
on s'en souvient et les victimes du
bataclan malheureusement s'en
souviennent aussi puisque les
terroristes ont utilisé le couloir
humanitaire en effet du passage d'été
syrien à l'époque c'est un homme qui a
changé d avis aussi sur l'aide médicale
d'état par exemple comprenait plus donc
je joue
il n'a pas un peu centralisée marine le
pen est ce qu'elle a pas rendu moins
dure abbas qui est sûr c'est qu'il a
pris les foudres à sa place
manifestement depuis le début
probablement et ça j'en suis convaincu
parce qu'il y avait beaucoup d'inconnues
dans la candidature d'eric zemmour et
que beaucoup l'ont vu et le voit encore
comme ayant une véritable capacité de
recomposer la vie politique française et
donc c'est vrai qu'il a subis on va dire
un traitement
corey subi quelques années encore marine
le pen à bien des égards et on peut
d'ailleurs s'étonner qu'elle même
parfois et repris des arguments de la
gauche qu'elle avait elle même subi fut
un temps avec des propos parfois très
dur ce que je trouve un peu un petit peu
dommage et justement est-ce que ça va
empêcher une réconciliation un
ralliement dans l'entre-deux tour entre
marine le pen et eric zemmour en tout
cas moi j'ai pris position là dessus
j'ai dit que je souhaitais qu'il puisse
y avoir la construction d'une majorité
parlementaire avec des coalitions au
sein des législatives législatives parce
que dans l'antre de tout aimé les
mairies et les deux les deux ça vous
allait favoriser les deux sont très
souvent incohérents moi j'ai dit
personnellement que si marine le pen
était qualifié bon évidemment je voterai
chapelle je voterai pour elle
j'appellerai à voter pour elle du fait
de l'opposition évidente à emmanuel
macron ce que je constate c'est qu'eric
zemmour à de très nombreuses reprises à
envoyer des signaux il a dit qu'il était
prêt au dialogue il a dit qu'il était
prêt à la discussion à réfléchir à des
alliances donc il y est ouvert je ne
sais pas quel est l'état d'esprit du
rassemblement national de ce point de
vue là c'est vrai que c'est un peu plus
difficile à saisir au regard des propos
comme vous l'avez rappelé de marine le
pen très dur sur sur eric zemmour
candidat de la guerre civile fait un
bond et chose assez étonnante donc je ne
sais pas ce qu'il en sera ça me rassure
près ça ça m'a surpris parce que je vous
dise il me faut de plus moi je je viens
du front national donc je les ai vécu à
l'époque j'ai souvenir d'avoir entendu
les mêmes reproches faits à marine le
pen on peut retourner au
marine le pen
elle ne vous met pas dans le même sac
pardon pour l'ex précieux pour
l'expression que les autres a dit mais
marion maréchal c'est pas pareil elle
avait quitté le rnb pas quoi si ce soit
mais ce qui est vrai c'est que je moi
j'avais quitté le front national depuis
maintenant longtemps que j'avais pas de
2,2 voir on va dire de loyauté à l'égard
du mouvement j'avais plus de mandats
donc j'étais libre de ce point de vue là
mais j'allais revenir je ne me vois pas
retourner au rassemblement national
puisque je les quitter pour deux pour de
bonnes raisons je n'ai quitté parce que
je ne me sentais plus en phase à
l'époque avec la ligne avec la stratégie
défendue et je me vois plus c'est pas
quelque chose de personnel je suis pas
dans un règlement de comptes à l'égard
de qui compte je suis vraiment dans un
sujet politique et le sujet politique
aujourd'hui pour moi c'est que eric
zemmour réussi à poser des fondations
que j'appelle de mes voeux depuis
longtemps et je vois dans l'équipe à
laquelle j'appartiens aujourd'hui des
digues tomber entre les droites et je
crois que c'est là demain que peut se
jouer la recomposition de la vie
politique à niveau à ce qu'un meeting
commun le pen est mort dans
l'entre-deux-tours ça vous paraît
probable bas en tout cas eric zemmour a
pas fermé la porte si jamais il y avait
des allures et donc voilà bah ce que
j'aimerais c'est que marine viennent au
meeting d'eric zemmour qualifiés aux
merci d'avoir été notre invitation a été
lancée elle tient évidemment d'eric
zemmour merci beaucoup merci fabrice ans
[Musique]